it's time for screen junkies movie
fights today's episode of movie fights
is brought to you by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make it with Squarespace
hey what's going on everybody its the
movie fights we're doing it again we are
fighting about movies and we have three
competitors one of them will walk out of
here a victor two of them will walked
out of here non victors
so they are all from a podcast that we
are brand new fans of here and excited
to meet them excited to introduce them
let's get it on
so the first up he is a comedian he is
the owner of a brand new car that maybe
he'll elaborate on if we ask him to and
he is the host of the kill Tony podcast
Tony Hinchcliffe good to be here yeah
Tony you want to talk about the new car
at all sure you set me up for it I sped
over here I was bragging to my friends
about how quickly I got here cuz I got a
I got a brand new souped-up Corvette
damn yeah my mom's in town I flew her in
for our big five year anniversary
episode a few days ago and she got to
drive around with me complaining and
holding on for dear life so I put on an
old Anita Ward ring my bell and just
turned it on okay yeah she loved it
changed her whole mood love it man
cruisin with your mom in a Corvette to
ring my bell hashtag bucket list
hello Tony thanks so much for being here
brother second he is the co-creator and
co-host of the kill Tony podcast Bryan
red bag what's up so when I first
thought your name was red band like a
red band trailer that's what it was
originally named after actually Wow it's
a projection that's a long time ago AOL
number one and had to pick out a screen
name but red band was a bank so like I
was like I you know I just dropped the D
it's still you know that's a thing I
love that because those trailers are a
little extra spicy yeah yeah the thing
that how I found out about red band
trailer because this is a long long time
ago before internet there was a movie
with Rodney Dangerfield
yeah Dangerfield yeah one of his last
movies ladybugs
it was the dirty water neat mr.
something me Wally sparks thank you Dan
for fact-checking intro and retail he's
on it we got the movies really rendering
Basel yeah maybe
we're going down to Wally sparks revin
right we got the movie trailer in the
movie theater it had a red band around
it I had never seen it before and I was
like what is this weird thing you know
and that's how I found out about red
band trailer sounds like that's a cool
name
yeah oh well I didn't even I don't even
realize they would come like that I just
thought yeah it's just went around most
of them and then one time I had a red
band that all makes sense there you go
Brian thank you so much man and this
gentleman on the end he's a very funny
comedian you've probably seen him on
Comedy Central's roast battles and he's
guest and he's part of every week of
kill Tony
Jeremiah walk-ins yes proud owner of a
98 Acura CL everybody what's up you know
I did not race over here I chugged along
but made it just in time ahead of Tony
surprisingly you know what I mean I'm
not usually one to promote inter movie
fight betting but if you guys want to go
pink pink slips on this it's up to you
Jeremiah thank you so much for being
here thank all three of you for being
here and real quick for the uninitiated
you want to just give us a sense of what
your podcast is or sum it up in a kind
of thumbnail yeah every week we at The
Comedy Store on the Sunset Strip in LA
one of the great comedy clubs of the
world oh yeah we we have a show where
anybody gets an opportunity to sign up
for a bucket and their name goes into a
bucket and I have two or one or two
guests every week that always come on
and if your name gets pulled out of the
bucket you get to do 60 seconds of
stand-up comedy on stage in front of me
and my guests panelists and in red ban
and the band which is led by Jeremiah
and they get 60 seconds uninterrupted
and then we interview them about
anything in the world we find out more
about their lives in front of a big live
audience and streaming live all around
the world so they're really in the
pressure cooker they don't know
they're gonna get pulled out or when
they're gonna get pulled out so we get
really genuine answers and that fun
nervous energy of somebody getting an
opportunity in Hollywood which so rarely
happens anymore unless you're basically
pulled out of a bucket right and a wacky
crazy sound effects and lighting changes
and music and just so many fun elements
and characters and return gas and
amazing how do those lighting changes
translate on the podcast they actually
translate really well it's a video
podcast all right he's a lot of fun and
I think a lot of people listen to both
audio and then on some of them they'll
go back and watch the video if they hear
extra laughs then I don't quite get so
it's sort of fun that sounds great
something ridiculously fun yeah as the
band we we commit to different
characters every single week so we're
improvising as different characters so
you're coming to kill Tony and you're
watching stand up you're gonna see
improv characters sketch it's kind of
the best of music there's someone's
drawing the episode is a guy Ryan J belt
who draws every single episode every
single week we've streamed it in VR 360
so you could literally put on a helmet
and all of a sudden be in the main room
of the comedy store which if you try to
find video of it it's almost impossible
that room because they don't even allow
video team but you know we got in very
early on with them and established
something so cool that the Comedy Store
lets us do that so very cool yeah Comedy
Store one of the great comedy venues in
the world for those of you who are not
here in LA and yeah that sounds awesome
kill Tony thanks guys appreciate you
being here so just a reminder how this
works we've got three judges votes
myself and then the Dan cam the Dan's
first up Dan Merle Dan how's it goin
brother I'm doing well how hairy basil
had a co-writing credit unbe Wally
sparks it was directed by Peter bulblets
so Wow just warming up the fact-checking
nice nice on the spot I'll
anything Harry basil will accept his
director credit that Jeremiah gave that
too yeah that's what the pedia pays just
change and the voice of the people the
delightful and amazing Daniel Radford
okay so the way that this works is that
there is going to be a pool that goes up
on the YouTube there are some fun polls
on the Twitter we do encourage you
along with those with the one that
counts for this is the one on YouTube so
in case of a tie you guys are the tie
breakers the poles do not go up until
all of the fighters have given their
answers because we don't want people
going ahead and picking before they have
a chance to hear the arguments cuz it's
based on the arguments also if you have
any questions about how that works go
down to the description below it will
explain you can also ask the chat will
be in there kind of helping y'all out
and go to Twitter to the hashtag movie
fights live where I will be looking
through for any kind of from you know
funny comments dank memes dank memes SiC
AF memes as our buddy here says we have
so I'll be going through and looking for
your comments send me some funny stuff
I'll be looking at it at a hashtag movie
fights laugh awesome Thank You Danielle
and just a quick a quick refresher on
how the game works three players the
first player to four points wins there
are three regular round questions that
will be decided by myself dan and
Danielle being the conduit of your poll
then we go into a speed round after that
and the speed round questions Danielle
will be giving her very own opinions and
Dan and myself will be weighing in as
well and again someone going to the
speed round down 300 but once you hit
that speed round anything is possible
you can come back and take it for three
man it's yeah it's good times before we
kick the game off let's go to Dan Merle
with some thoughts we have a sponsor
yeah so don't worry just 15 more minutes
in the final start I promise before we
get to our first round we do want to
give a shout out to our friends at
Squarespace for sponsoring today's show
if you didn't know what already a
Squarespace makes it very easy for you
to do really create whatever identity
you want online do whatever you want to
do if you want to make a kill Tony
fanpage if you want to start an online
feud with the John Travolta movie you
can do it on Squarespace you can it's
all one platform 24/7 customer support
dozen to install patch or upgrade ever
check out squarespace.com for a free
trial and if you're ready to launch your
own site to talk about whatever you want
to towel ups the last Jedi which is
everyone in our chats talking about for
some reason I don't know we haven't even
mentioned Star Wars go to
squarespace.com slash screen junkies to
save 10
sent off your first purchase of a
website or domain so you know make a
page say some stuff out there you go
make a page dedicate it to your favorite
subject matter and without further ado
jte drop that package
[Music]
[Applause]
what a delicious package that was oh
yeah jte may be the most delicious
package in the biz so our first question
there user reviews vs. critics reviews
for the John Travolta film gaudy have
been a hot topic of discussion
especially between Dan and various
parties online so we are asking the
question what's the worst movie that was
beloved by critics the worst movie that
was beloved by critics and we'll start
with the man to my left
Tony Hinchliffe okay I believe this is a
wiz I would consider this one of my more
controversial takes on this show here
today so let's just get it right started
I think the worst movie that was beloved
by critics was Citizen Kane I think that
every time I look at some of the great
movies of all time for some reason this
hunk of garbage is number one it really
makes no sense to me
it's like saying the best song ever was
from Beethoven like it's like just old
junk let's face it a story's a story
this is a better book than a movie I'm
not impressed by how it's shot it's not
even in color I mean let's get real I
get it it's the hip thing to do to say
oh it was the first great movie but it's
just nothing I mean I've never seen it
but really mad that it's number one not
on everything I mean I look at movies
like Pulp Fiction and Goodfellas and I
think to myself there's no way that this
old hunky black and white old garbage
movie can compete I refuse to watch it
I'm sick of seeing it called number one
by so many people that's that's my take
alright Tony hates old stuff my mom
she's 17
thanks Tony Bryan hey so this movie's
got is very controversial also for me
since this is loved by not only critics
but a lot of people alright and it's
called snowpiercer and man I hate this
movie and you know the big reason I hate
it it's it's a Weinstein Company film so
I don't
I don't need to describe it anymore
right guys no I should it it takes place
on the most boring form of
Transportation a train like I mean they
tried the bus they couldn't do the bus
any more speed did that already it's
just it's very there's so many loopholes
in this this movie not only is it take
place in a train sometimes the Train is
bigger sometimes it's like 50 feet high
other times it's a small little train
there's parts where a guy slips on a
fish like a banana it's ridiculous that
special effects look like cutscenes from
ps3 or a screensaver and there's
thousands of people on this train and
there are drinking alcohol on one of
them like where are they getting this
alcohol they've been on here for 18
years
they're just having rave parties every
single night where did all these people
poop like where's our days they sleep
there's describe any of this they act
like all these people just hang out on a
nightclub and drink all day that's not
true
and there's baby eating in it we can't
have a movie that's just horrible
babies are amazing and if you like the
sound effects in it you could you can
open up your iPhone because half of them
are ringtones cuz that's how horrible
this movie is alright Brian coming in
hot with a lot of train logistics
Jeremiah what do you have to add here
for me I chose Birdman yeah Oh a
horrible look at that stupid Larry oh my
goodness that do I even have to continue
after looking at that dumb picture
probably right I probably do this movie
is more of a gimmick to me than a good
movie oh who would film something in
only one shot and think it's a good idea
hahaha I mean who would who would be so
egotistical to think that that could
pass as being the one good thing rather
than having the good content in the
movie oh we're gonna make his whole
bunch
and then people aren't gonna pay
attention to the the annoying acting and
the subpar plot that's going on Michael
Keaton Ennis he plays a guy who was a
superhero back in 1992 oh wow which is a
weird strange analogy for him playing
Batman back in the day we get it this is
a big Hollywood Stroke fest let's watch
another movie about Hollywood about
making plays and stuff about how hard it
is to be a struggling actor and
everything in a big comeback boo boring
didn't like it all right Jeremiah does
not like Hollywood patting themselves on
the back fight it out guys
first of all Birdman's not all shot in
one shot and some companies that do like
things shot in one shot Netflix little
known fact about Tony he has a special
that was on that little known fact
relation really I sell out all over the
road it's a little-known fact Jeremiah
little-known is that I don't see you
headlining out there you've permanent
feature getting personal right off the
back you said it's a big Hollywood movie
about the Hollywood industry it's all on
Broadway in New York City it's about the
theater industry it has nothing to do
with Hollywood not a citizen Hollywood
no it doesn't dude it has to do with
this old movie career and in moving on
on Broadway that seems pretty self
contained inside the industry to me
that's New York City that's a whole
nother city you keep saying Hollywood
it's Broadway it's all shocking nextrip
Hollywood as the industry of filmmaking
and playmaking and everything that
Michael Citizen Kane is just too old to
compare do anything you can't you you
you just because it's old and it's
out-of-date like you can't even compare
all this a beautiful movie problem old
and out-of-date never stopped you from
doing a Kings of Leon impression on
stage that crushes and it is don't make
me fire it up right here right now on
screen junkies he's going inside okay
he's want to go inside baseball career
what we really mister don't
something in one shot I'm going inside
baseball I'm hitting this out of the
park
I think Birdman is definitely a horrible
horrible horrible movie not as bad as
snowpiercer and definitely not as bad as
Citizen Kane citizen Kane's probably a
classic I also have not seen it but it
seems like it's black and white so it's
probably good I'm sorry if you smoke
good you know if you sit down and watch
it I'm sure it's a I'm sure it's pretty
decent well you say if you smoke what
no one's rating this is are we in Disney
but there could be smoke a joint and
watch Citizen Kane it's probably pretty
badass so like two out of the three
people on this panel have not seen
Citizen Kane is that correct have you
yes I have hashtag rosebud ashtag
Jedediah one of the main characters it's
the sleigh right nice that's a good
movie well I liked snowpiercer
I loved Birdman Michael Keaton one of
the great actors of all time who was in
who was in Citizen Kane any your
favorite actors how about Orson Welles
do you know that I named an actor from
it and I haven't even seen it losers
I mean you you cut me off and you're
being very rude but I can cut somebody
often call them O'Brien I want to hear a
little bit more from you why is your
movie worse than Birdman in your
restaurant okay well at least I hated
Birdman but Birdman at least was filmed
kind of unique it was a unique movie I
give it that so it's near its narrow
peers here
snare starts no it's snarf so what's
snowpiercer but Birdman at least was
kind of okay to watch Michael Keaton's
an amazing actor where snowpiercer had
some good acting but also had some of
the worst acting like there was parts
where a guy had his arm out the window
and it's freezing off like it's being
frozen and he was screaming for about
two minutes
and then he just stopped screaming and
just hanging out there and somebody puts
a shoe on his head and it's just it's
just silly goofy dumb stuff and I did
not like it at least Birdman I I would
show my mom and she'd probably say it's
pretty bad but she was okay but I can't
show my mom's snowb here so she's like
what is this garb
uh it looks like a cutscene from an old
video scheme jeremiah anything to rebut
on that I mean the acting is just as bad
to me in Birdman I wouldn't believe for
a second that Emma Watson was ever
Michael Keaton's daughter why miss Emma
Stone excuse me Emma Stone Oh the
Internet's not gonna like that
it's the acting wasn't convincing for me
just like it felt like like her tears
were so forced that somebody was putting
Visine in her eyes between the takes and
you know that's what I'm gonna say about
that between the takes you yourself said
it was one take one minute left one
minute left you guys any other thoughts
you know Birdman and snowpiercer both
had beautiful color beautiful color
schemes which tells a part of the story
they both have underlying you know
storylines that are trying to describe
you what's going on in the main
character's minds again Citizen Kane
boring alright Wow okay a lot of
revelations here are some interesting
arguments Dan facts checked yeah okay
not not based on a book you've never
seen the movie but it's not based on a
book it is loosely inspired by William
Randolph Hearst life its original
screenplay by Herman mankiewicz and
Orson Welles it is black and black and
white I can confirm that and it is
considered by most people to be a
classic which I can also go on the
record right now saying I freaking love
all time by the AFI among many other
organizations but you know that's I mean
they're almost act here not opinion
anyway Birdman
did win the Oscar for Best
Cinematography again not saying that
that everybody any particular argument
however the Academy recognized the way
that it was shot and directed however
did not win any acting awards despite
Michael Keaton considered by many to be
a heavy favorite for Best Actor did not
win who took Best Actor that year do you
know
I believe it was was leo was it Leo that
year I don't remember
Napoli hook up it might have been here
before Leo on it had to look up who won
best activate you thank you it was not
Michael Keaton like a gotcha do you
think Leo won for Django they do think
so right no Leo went for the revenue
yeah yeah that's what I meant
anyway based on all of your arguments
Tony you know I was I was listening to
you with open ears but then you
completely lost me when you said you
hadn't seen the movie yeah I can't count
that I know I didn't know whether or not
I wanted to admit that but it was worth
it for the laugh it was worth it for the
laugh and at the end of the day the you
know laughs are a good thing but on
movie fights yeah that that puts you in
a third place out of three this round so
it comes down to Brian and Jeremiah and
you're both arguing for films that I
enjoyed but Brian your opening salvo you
laid out point by point things you
really didn't like about it and you
actually caused me to take pause and
think about that goddamn weird train
yeah that was really weird train and it
could like that derailed me a little why
couldn't they just stop the train why
did they have to go in circle they could
just stop and lo because they like they
freeze or something no they could have
the engine on trains do it all the time
you know what maybe we'll find out if
snowpiercer - you get my point
let's go over - damn Eddie Redmayne that
defeated Michael cute oh yes girl the
theory of everything theory of
everything yeah yeah it was between
snowpiercer surprisingly it was between
snowpiercer
for me that they're not seeing a thing
is is really I do think that was a
critical error in judgment to admit to
because I think you could have made the
same arguments without admitting that
you hadn't seen the movie I think you
discount some of your opinions by
admitting than not having seen it so
good laugh but no point for me I'm gonna
have to say between snowpiercer and
Birdman I felt like it was both personal
preference and III got a more kind of
visceral take on what the problems with
the movie actually for Birdman so that's
her I'm gonna have to throw my vote all
right it's
tied up one one that means we're going
to the poll to decide Danielle all right
I just refreshed and we've got with 50%
of the votes snowpiercer 32 percent of
the vote goes to Birdman and Citizen
Kane with 17 percent
there you go Brian you get the point
Oh is there any other suggestions before
we close up on Jeremiah's post point
cast but there were a lot of people
saying la-la-land we had a couple very
vocal people saying that they thought
that Wonder Woman was underwhelming on
Twitter at David Bowman 4-4-2 said the
Johnny Depp remake of Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory has an 83% tomato
rating that is offensive someone accused
Dan of not like in kourtney's I don't
think that's true
no that's her if that's a horrific
allegation to make patently untrue
number one I got all excited to tell you
that the Queen's corgis I love corgis as
everyone does carnies are just fine all
right
it is one o brien going into round
fun fact about snowpiercer
if you watch the movie it has the number
seven in it about 20 times okay maybe
you know reason maybe it's influential
in some way trying to put number seven
in your head what's it on you I guess
question number two so will ferrell will
be doing a movie based on the eurovision
music contest for netflix we asked what
is the best Will Ferrell movie what is
the best Will Ferrell movie and it's
question number two we're gonna start
with player number two Brian's one of
the best things about where Will Ferrell
is when he is silly and goofy he's not
serious in my movie that I chose his
stepbrothers which i think completely
showcases the silly side of both john c
reilly and Will Ferrell and to the point
where always of all the other movies
they've done in the past they're all
pretty good like Talladega Nights and
and stuff like that but this one really
gets to the core of what I think why we
like those two together just just silly
goofy funny
manchild loving good stuff stepbrothers
from Brian Jeremiah I chose blades of
glory might be a controversial
controversial choice but what I will say
is if we're talking Will Ferrell movies
specifically now with an ensemble or
anything else this movie could not exist
without Will Ferrell that role could not
have been played by anybody else very
quotable just like many Will Ferrell
movies but this is the only movie out of
any Will Ferrell movie including a lot
of movies that was included in the 2011
hit inwards in Paris by Kanye West and
jay-z a line listed directly from that
it has been played billions of times
across the world and that is from
directly from that being a hit amazing
unforgettable movie oh yeah is it in the
the talk over par
in the beginning of the song we're gonna
skate to one song one song yeah god I
didn't know that Thank You Jeremiah
background to Tony I straight with AI
this one's a no-brainer to me I think
these guys are way off course I'm going
with the classic I'm not gonna be
controversial on this one at all it's a
no-brainer the best Will Ferrell movie
and you could say your little ensemble
thing but every comedy movie has an
ensemble in fact he's the co-star of the
movie that you named he's one half of
the ensemble that remember the co-stars
name yeah it's the the beautiful name
that only worked once Jon Heder yeah
that's it
yeah but I mean like as a main guy but
he split that movies on the cover and
everything with Will Ferrell its
anchorman people it's blatantly the
funniest movie undefeated undisputed
undisputed you can't beat it look how
small Steve Carell is on that I mean
it's he was just a part of the ensemble
because Will Ferrell shows his true
muscle I agree with Brian on will is
that his best obviously goofy and silly
that's why he's a full-time comedic
actor and he blows the rest of his
ensemble out of the water on this
absolutely unbelievable I've never been
able to look at the local news the same
since then I feel like a lot of people
feel this way I think he used you
picture a guy that reads anything that's
written on a prompter I think of this
movie every time I see the news every
time I see a teleprompter every time I
see Will Ferrell and for the record you
have seen the movie yes many times many
times
all right gentlemen fight it out well
anchorman needs a lot of people in the
movie just to make it good I think
you're not relying on just Will Ferrell
you're relying on seven other people
anchorman is a great movie and I think
we all enjoyed it but once anchorman 2
came out and we all saw it we kind of
kind of it took us a couple steps down I
think I think anchorman 2 kind of kind
of hurt the the brand where's that
brothers is a one shot it's a it's white
it's gonna be a classic they're not
going to ruin it with a sequel you can
watch that thing a million times and
still laugh your ass no they're not
going to make a sequel because it wasn't
that good of
oh I would disagree with that because if
you want to hear bad movies you'd listen
to Jeremiah's choice which I don't even
know is a movie I remember seeing that
and I thought that was just a skit on
Saturday Night Live that went straight
to video that that movie is awful Jeremy
I don't know why you would even pick
that movie that gross I mean there's so
many more better movies than that like
Will Ferrell come on let me just say
anchorman grossed more money
it got its own sequel - whereas none of
your movies did and trust me these
companies want to be able to make
sequels to their make sequels they just
made different movies isn't that really
part of the problem everybody more
sequels to movies it should have just
been kept for the boat fare Jeremiah I'm
not saying that sequels are a good thing
I'm saying the movie is so good that it
had sequels also and you saying that
nobody else could have done what Will
Ferrell did in blades of glory might be
the silliest thing I've ever heard
because you're not a casting director
and it's uh it was written by writers so
he was just doing what he was written by
yeah I know I'm one of them I'm in the
writers guild unlike you so anyway my
point is is that he's being told what to
do by the funny brains that tell him
what to do in the director that tells
him what to do so you saying that nobody
else could have done that just wrong
anchorman is just overrated okay this is
overrated
everybody wants to hop on the bandwagon
of this big ensemble picture read you
some catchphrases real quick
I love limp 60% of the time it works
every time whammy I read somewhere that
periods attract bears bears can smell
the menstruation you know what all of
those have in common
Will Ferrell did not say any of those
lines that's right you want to hear some
quotes that I heard during blades of
glory I want my money back I have to use
the back
through this movies slow when is it over
I can see why this movie came out on
video this movie was ahead of its time
it pushed the boundaries on what people
were comfortable watching two men doing
together and it helped gay rights that's
all lies everyone knows stepbrothers is
the best maybe why could you elaborate
on that well I mean everyone knows
having a stepbrother is one of the worst
things ever and when you're a 30 40 year
old manchild and you get another 30 or
40 year old manchild put in the same
room together
let the hilarities fly because there is
nothing but goofy silly fun in this
movie and it's a no-stress like
anchorman kind of stresses you out here
and there you know like oh he lost his
job you don't have to have stress out on
this it's just non-stop yeah Larry wait
you're talking about the stress thing
that's called a storyline that's called
getting sometimes you don't want that
sometimes you just want to watch them go
crazy on each other and have a germ off
at the end and the ending of
stepbrothers might be one of the most
beautiful moments in the rug win when
Will Ferrell is saying that whatever
that song is and John's he rides like
I'm leaving here doing the John's you
know that guy remember at the end at
their wedding reception it was like like
a five-minute song that Will Ferrell's
saying john c reilly and adam scott
outshine Will Ferrell instead brothers
and while you guys brag about your
sausagefest movies let me just remind
you christina applegate
never hotter than she was in anchorman 1
well you were wrong because there's a
lot of great movies that christina
applegate did some of them uh what was
the bad neighbor babysitting one what
was that maybe remember that don't tell
Mom the babysitter's dead hotter than
ever
Wow Brian I didn't realize you were into
sixteen-year-old girls she was at the
time she was not 16
and at the time I lived in a state where
that was legal okay I want to get some
pie I want to get some final thoughts on
your movie anything you want to say
right now that will tell us why your
movie is the best Will Ferrell or any
other aspersions you want to cast on the
other movies and we'll start with Bryan
well first I think we all know that
Jeremiah's choice was was we shouldn't
even count it because none of us care
about that movie at all and it's
probably Weinstein maybe also and
anchorman let's be honest we're all kind
of sick of that movie it's been shown a
million times if the sequel kind of give
us all a buzzkill a little and but when
you see Step Brothers hit the TV you
will sit down and watch that movie no
matter what because that is just a silly
fun movie which definitely represents
some of the best of Will Ferrell Thank
You Bryan
Jeremiah I think this was in the era of
when a lot of sports comedy films were
being made and I feel like it was a
standout among all the other comedies
that were being made of there's so many
Will Ferrell sports movies semi-pro
kicking and screaming the list goes on
but um
it's just it's it's a stand-up movie
that showcases Will Ferrell and like I
said nobody can can play that role
except Will Ferrell and nobody can make
that movie work and you almost forget
who is in the rest of the movie outside
of Will Ferrell because he's such a show
stealer Thank You Jeremiah Tony you
forget who else is in the movie cuz
there is nobody else in it maybe John
haters and number two any almost blows
Will Arnett Namie Pollard names some
more my absolute not favorites anyway
look I get it people it's the hip thing
to say that the big moneymaker isn't the
best but it's undeniable Steve Carell is
like number four or five on this movie
on hilarity levels
compared to your amy poehler and what is
it will forte will earn it will arnett
my goodness yeah he's amazing don't tell
Mom the babysitter's dead anchorman is
great for a reason they made a sequel
for a reason it's cuz it's great there's
a reason why it's shown so much it's cuz
it's great it's the best of all time no
doubt about it
alright time there you have it let's go
to Dan Merle with facts and his opinion
on this battle sure effects Adam McKay
as recently as last month said that the
sequel to Step Brothers hasn't been
ruled out he says it's possible but it's
not actively in the works the song that
will Ferrell sing at the end of that
movie was called por ti Volare
and she's applica because it was brought
up christina applegate was 19 years old
don't kill tell mama baby should his dad
came out right gross anyway yeah I think
that I thought that Tony had by far the
best opening and I kind of kept waiting
for people to sort of knock him down a
little bit and I never really heard an
argument about anchorman that stuck I
don't think that the sequel is relevant
to the first movie and how good the
first movie is blades of glory
unfortunately nothing there really
worked for me and I felt that Tony's
arguments both from the film and then
his counters were better so I'm gonna go
with anchorman yeah great so that's one
for Tony and anchorman yeah I was I was
close to going to Bryant with Brian on
stepbrothers but I just didn't get
enough specifics about the movie cuz
stepbrothers oh man it's got a play
there's like a really special place in
my heart for stepbrothers good is it
because it is so frigging dumb I loved
it but yeah that didn't sell it for me
Jeremiah
I appreciate what you were saying about
like to hear their view of my answer
they all like you took the words right
out of my mouth here's a here's a little
inside baseball if we talked about you
first you're probably not gonna get the
point talk about you second you know
Tony gets it what does another line say
about it though yeah let's go to
Danielle
alright so Tony you officially got that
what if I get above 2 percent I'm gonna
be thrilled
all right well let me go ahead and
refresh 2 percent is also a blades of
glory has on Rotten Tomatoes wait 60
percent of the vote anchorman 25% of the
vote goes to stepbrothers and blades of
glory coming in with 13 percent of the
vote some other movies that were
mentioned lego movie was one that a lot
of people were into Talladega Nights
convention a lot of people really
identified with stranger than fiction
which I thought was was a neat inclusion
with old school I feel like to get
stabbed in the neck with a tranquilizer
I I don't know if I've laughed harder
than all of them will Ferrell movies got
mentioned everyone's got a favorite Will
Ferrell movie it's good to know good to
know what I will say more inside
baseball is whenever we were sent the
questionnaire and the the choices those
were my two choices and the third choice
was blades of glory and I had to defend
it to the best of my ability which was
not strong enough right no it was not
Tony at that point more inside baseball
back to you in the studio
Jeremiah thank you sir okeydoke it is a
1-1 Brian and Tony going into round
number three
so Jurassic world fallen Kingdom opens
this weekend we asked our contestants
pitch an entire amusement park based on
any movie an entire amusement park based
on any movie and this is the third
question we start with player number
three Jeremiah I chose Lord of the Rings
alright we'll come back to you to hear
more in just a moment back around to
Tony wow you didn't really explain my no
we moved on let's just everyone give
their choice in eloping ok I'll explain
mine later I mean I cannot wait to
explain it yeah I'm very confident in it
and my amusement park is Goodfellas
Goodfellas amusement park Brian you guys
know this one is a no-brainer especially
if you love time travel back to the
future
it's alright there you have it Jeremiah
with Lord of the Rings Tony with
Goodfellas Brian with Back to the Future
gentlemen fight it out ok what's good
what an amusement park view Goodfellas -
no I was hoping that we were gonna
establish our amusement parks up front
but I'll just go for it right now yeah
you know every amusement park let me
just start off by saying Lord of the
Rings there already is a Harry Potter
world those amusement parks are
completely alright I think we found a
Lord of the Rings nerd everybody Harry
Potter
it's literally worlds apart literally
yeah they both have Gandalf in them lady
right here about the spaghetti land
right yeah yeah
you are about to this is a completely
original idea I there's pasta land over
here there's the rigatoni rides of the
game kill a bomb in the mr. our points
is losing his mind over there let's hear
from Tony yes thank you give us a taste
of this at one point four is yours for a
moment thank you so this is a completely
original idea unlike the you know silly
action movies that these guys picked I
figured you know this could be like a
classier type of more fun a different
type of amusement park for adults not
children this is an adult amusement park
idea where you wear a suit you get
dressed up the ladies go in looking nice
there's unbelievable food sure you can
call it spaghetti land and disgrace my
Italian heritage Jeremiah but I don't
know if you've seen the food in
Goodfellas but even the food in prison
looks good they got lobsters in ice
chests they're slicing the garlic so
thin with a razor that it liquefies in
the pan with just a little bit can I ask
you a question yes are you merely
describing a casino just a fancy casino
no it's called a gentlemen's club
Jeremiah there's really cool cars like
the cars that they steal in the
beginning of that movie but they're all
on really fast tracks you know red band
Brian and I are both from the great
state of Ohio that as the number one
amusement park in the world Cedar Point
there and we know that that you can make
amazing rides you could give cool
separate cars
you know like convertibles and Corvettes
and Eska all the Cadillacs that they
drive in Goodfellas you'd go through a
walk through the Copacabana just like
that scene that they take and there's
other fun things happening you know it's
an adult amusement park with good music
throughout all right a little bit about
Goodfellas uh
tell us some of the amenities it back to
the future Brian well check this out
guys this is pretty sweet because not
only is it one amusement park it's
multiple purim use mint parks and it's
different time periods so let's say you
start off at current time you're in your
downtown well what is actually at Warner
Brothers Studios you know your clock
tower you got the nice little places to
eat you got current rides like roller
coasters and and fun things to go to but
hey let's go back in time let's go back
in the you know the old days now we have
old carousels we have old rides that
they used to have back in the old times
we have different things from the movies
also like remember that poop truck that
they a bit like ran into well that's
also an ice-cream shop now you got
soft-serve ice cream there you got you
know they've got the old diners you got
the old movie theaters and it's just
like hey let's go to another time period
you get into your DeLorean and you go on
this DeLorean ride where it takes you
into the future now you're at Biff's big
Tower is Trump Tower and you've got
these VR rides you you got all that
the newest special effects that you can
get on a rides right now and it's pretty
cool because it's it's taking you to all
these different time periods that you
remember from the movie but it's also
doing all the technology that was
available for rides at that time and
food and diners and entertainment so
it's actually going on to like you know
like a a whole bunch of amusement parks
you great thanks Brian Jeremiah I want
to hear a little bit more about yours
Lord of the Rings world yes I'm so glad
that Tony brought up Harry Potter world
a very very successful theme park this
is has a the only thing that this would
share with Harry Potter world is how
successful would be for all ages this is
a welcoming environment for not only
adults and weird people who want to
relive mafia moments and stuff like that
uh you you this is an entire universe
well similar so it's like all amusement
parks okay it's like every amusement
park ever alright look good never mind
the floor for a second John is a
shooting range go ahead
okay dressed up at a shooting range go
ahead all right great
that's definitely not gonna help your
argument on this one um middle-earth
let's talk about it yeah there are so
many different destinations that you can
so many different destinations that you
can go to on middle-earth there could be
kids rides and the Shire okay starting
off at the very beginning of your
journey yes and then Mordor is more of
the extreme roller coaster rides that
you have to be older to get on and you
may even have to sign a waiver because
it's so scary
throughout the park there's different
creatures that are adding to your
environments there's there's orcs
there's Balrog there's river maids
there's goblins there's ring race
they're there it's almost in some parts
it's like a it's like a haunted like
Halloween Horror Nights like it and in
different sections of the park and as
you go on the journey through the Lord
of the Rings the rides get more and more
like complex and got every fight it out
you guys well one Jeremiah has chosen a
treat ridiculous like no one wants to go
to the to that Lord of the Rings saying
that sounds like the dumbest thing ever
and like whoa good names that we don't
have and good fellows I mean I mean
that's a great great great movie but how
bored are you gonna be hanging out with
those Italians you talk more about the
ice cream and the hamburgers available
at this part or the net actually being
let me mention something that I think
about how about riding hoverboards kids
what did you love to ride a hoverboard
using the newest technology Wow
your your amusement park just got shut
down by a lawsuit after one day
oh no he also mentioned the time periods
thing I don't know how far we're gonna
go back with this but certain time
periods in the past were nothing nicest
to all races of people oh so I don't
know if that's a good idea it might be a
touchy subject to bring you don't like
riding horses and you don't like being
on trains everyone loves trains trains
is the best form of transportation
can I just say that I love that Jeremiah
just brought up all races is a thing
because I believe that there are no
black people in any of the Lord of the
Rings movies where Goodfellas features a
young unknown named samuel l.jackson as
the driver in that movie thank you very
much well it's just parts of Lord of the
Rings that they decided to not show but
they definitely exist in the world Jar
Jar Binks with black
okay well that this is a completely
different question we're arguing now
let's stick with the UH newsroom the
actor whom Oh captain yeah so keep going
Jeremiah any other any other fellow show
you talking about is a amusement park we
got there might wake up no there's so
many different like epic scenes that are
in The Lord of the Rings that could just
take place like the mines of moria and
and the different like what would be
cool about this too is there's
possibilities for escape rooms within
this
gotcha less than a minute left you guys
alright so I mean you know my idea is
different because it's not an
all-inclusive you know kid this is like
I said it's Arden right waiting for that
point like I said you dress up there's a
shooting range people imagine being an
adult alright freeze one final thing for
everybody I want you to give us a 15 to
20 second commercial as a comical
character that would appear at your
amusement park give us a commercial for
your amusement park starting with
Jeremiah three two one go oh yes
here the Lord of the Rings everyone
shall pass as they come through the park
at every moment come to the Shire come
to the mines of war come to ride the
Balrog and every moment's notice
there will be time and time again to
share fun with Hanlin adventures of all
ages of all races and all creeds are
welcome here at Lord of the remind that
was real good ok
back around - Tony give us a commercial
for the good fellows ever since I was a
kid I always knew I wanted to be an
amusement park goer keep them here Jimmy
keep him here Jimmy they were good times
they were good food they were good
fellows I could fellas amusement park
all right for any good for any good
echoing the opening of actual Goodfellas
Brian
[Music]
alright man 3 amusement parks that will
never open damn just a sample of effect
factual things there have been rumors
that Universal Studios will add lure the
Rings to its potential Forest Park in
Orlando but that's never been you know
the the either the blogs the the the
theme park blogs they're always a buzz
that's been the latest buzz potentially
added to a fourth Park in Orlando for
Universal Studios the Clocktower it's
currently on the back lot of Universal
Studios in Hollywood not Warner Brothers
actually that came up and that's the
only factual information circulating in
otherwise uh so Tony I'm gonna talk
about you first you know what that means
you're not gonna get this point for
doing yeah it just seemed a little too
restrictive that no children would go
there I think that because when you
think amusement parks you need to bring
kids there and again you merely
described a casino but with the shooting
range that that was a fun aspect we'd
like to get dressed up and maybe go to a
shooting range yes okay so came down to
Jeremiah and Brian me I was really taken
by both of your pitches I think you both
described great amusement parks man all
three areas that you could go to but
then when you start to bring in the
Hollywood horror aspect like the the
Halloween amusement park with the the
scary characters ring wraiths walking
around very difficult decision for me
but at the end of the day I am man
Jeremiah won me over the Rings one Lord
of the Rings damn having sat in that
chair many times and that exact chair
that Jeremiah is sitting in I have seen
this happen before what happened in this
fight is what I like to call the Spencer
J Gilbert technique yes which is when
your opponents don't have a very good
counter argument against your pick
they just say that it's ridiculous and
start laughing at it and think that that
will sway the judges when in fact that
person has given thoroughly the best
argument for the question because the
only two of those two said he said that
his theme park when you'd ride in a car
and walk through a restaurant
he said you need ice cream out of a poop
truck and he pushed a theme-park so I'm
going with Jeremiah that's the point
scoreless no more oh hello mr. one point
[Applause]
with 58% Lord of the Rings back to the
future with 38% and Goodfellas coming in
at 2% have you ever seen a lower poll
than 2% 2% like the milk that the babies
are gonna turn get the Lord of the Rings
got either I've got a lot of mentions
guys we see you ready player one was one
that a lot of people these are both
little long so go to Nolan Dean 27 and I
do to do at Grace case stone both on
Twitter they both had some really
compelling arguments for How to Train
Your Dragon and grace case the stone
thought she was slick and put her
argument on top of a picture of a corgi
and yeah guys that works yeah apparently
Danielle thank you for that so we are
tied up at 1 1 & 1 so tiebreaker
jte nicely done with that tiebreaker
graphic coming in hot with that alright
so um we are going to ask I'm gonna ask
a question and then we will choose our
least favorite answer and the least
favorite answer will disqualify that
person will knock you out whoever asks
our least favorite answer and the other
two will move on to the speed round okay
and just shout out your answer as soon
as you hear the question and then we the
first person to speak will get twenty
seconds
second then the second person to speak
will go then the third person to speak
and then you'll all get a ten second
rebuttal does that make sense yeah great
all right here is your question
Incredibles 2 is tearing up the box
office
what Pixar film would have the best
live-action remake Toy Story and here's
why okay hold your thought we have Toy
Story we need answers from the other two
gents this action best live-action
remake of a Pixar film what Pixar movie
image tick-tock remember half the Pixar
movies right God names inks are moving
I think I won this one huh 500k Finding
Nemo Finding Nemo 5 wall-e wall-e ok
great so we have wall-e Toy Story
Finding Nemo 20 seconds begins Toni
whenever you speak I mean let's just get
it going here there's no doubt about it
because Toy Story is the one that didn't
take 20 seconds for my opponents to
think of it is the one that pushed Pixar
to the moon it's the reason why those
other movies even got a chance to be
made the compelling nature of getting to
watch actors play those types of roles
time one of the most beautiful things
about Little Nemo is that takes place
underneath the water and there's no like
special effects or there's no like fake
things those are actually what the fish
look like what the undergrow under the
water looks like so I think the backdrop
will be almost exactly the same like the
movie because it's going to be beautiful
fish and beautiful coral and beaut it's
gonna be beautiful because it is
beautiful inner blonde I am I think it
would be interesting to see a robot have
to take on the role of an animated thing
and the people that we currently live
with in the society as people are
getting fatter and people are like so
self consumed with entertainment I think
that time okay 10 second rebuttals 10
second Royals Jeremiah that was
ridiculous
I'm trying to think of something I'm
seeing Tony space easy it's a pressure
cooker up in here okay ten set all right
that's your 10 second rebuttal 10 second
rebuttal
okay Toy Story you know a live-action
may be the and I'll just be like
watching like disney on ice who cares
about that that movie yeah you didn't
give any kind of argument I think
beautiful underwater nature will always
win for a live-action movie
I'm gonna agree with Brian Redman on
this one that his choice is better than
Tony hinge clips and then I'd rather see
fish come to life then time all right
you know what we have some interesting
choices there but I gotta go Jeremiah
I'm gonna say it didn't quite measure up
I'm going to remind Danielle oh gosh
that's right I have my own opinions for
this one um don't wink at me I said I'll
do it again in your opinion who crapped
the bed the harness Jeremiah that puts
you out of the speed round but super
funny and some really fun answers thanks
and now maybe I'll have come to you for
some opinions on these this is the
greatest moment in sports that we know
of the speed round okay so we are tied
1-1 between Brian and Tony the way the
speed round works the first player to
four points walks away with a victory
and again it's going to work the same
way the tiebreaker worked okay I'll ask
the question first person to speak will
go first and then it's 20 seconds 20
seconds then 10 second rebuttal ten
second rebuttal gentlemen you ready yes
let's do this you're all in the podcast
world what movie character would host
the best comedy podcast
Wow
Will Ferrel what movie character
I gotcha here we go what more character
gentlemen our Johnson from the jerk yes
okay there you go so we have Forrest
Gump and we have Steve Martin's Navin R
Johnson from the jerk all right so we
heard Forrest Gump first Tony 20 seconds
begin whenever you speak every great
podcast host has something in common and
that is life experience if you look at
what Forrest Gump did the running the
war experience the ping pong playing the
love life everything he has so much to
draw from so much to talk about an
access to some of the best guests in the
world
thank you I rest my case under the 20
seconds with pompe 20 seconds with you
whenever you speak Brian it's a comedy
podcast and what what would you like to
hear a comedian Navin R Johnson is some
of the funniest things it's one of the
funniest characters of all time and him
hosting a comedy podcast makes sense
because his movies so funny his material
so funny and the time period that he
lives in would be hilarious
10 second rebuttal Tony yes nobody said
I don't believe did you say has to be a
comedy podcast or any comedy pot perfect
I still stand by Forrest all the way he
was funny throughout he had a natural
sense of humor that he can let his
guests be funnier than him on the show
whereas I feel like David would check
out China everyone knows that Forrest
Gump would be annoying to listen to he
would not have any kind of direction he
would probably just be slobbering all
over the mics
[Laughter]
I don't remember that scene zemeckis
direction where he drools Dan I gotta be
honest I would I wasn't feeling the
forest gump argument but I I didn't get
really anything to counter it so I gotta
go Tony all right that's one for Tony
Danielle um I I'm actually I'm gonna go
with Tony because I like the idea of him
allowing his guests to be funny and not
just him being funny that that's stuck
with me so I'm gonna go with Tony Tony
you get the point it is to one Tony
going into question number two the speed
round here we go we got our first photos
of Linda Hamilton returning to the role
of Sarah Connor what other actors should
return as an old version of one of their
classic characters okay I even our
Johnson Steve Martin okay Steve Martin
should come back as Navin R Johnson in
the jerk I'm going to go with I'm going
to go with on this one a return
character so this would be like a sequel
I just want to sort of don't understand
yeah
who should yeah in us in a sequel who
should play a character they played
years ago right okay I think that I
would like to see a Darth Vader have his
own movie is that the character of the
actor actor what other actor should
return as an old version of one of their
classic characters Thanks
okay I need the actor in the can I'm
gonna go with times of Harrison Ford
getting his own true Han Solo spin-off
Harrison Ford getting his own Han Solo
spinoff
okay you don't know what happened to
Hahn after return the Jedi do oh I guess
we go yeah it actually happened alright
and I have the second point go sir okay
we have the answers 20 seconds of Gillen
I think everyone's one of everyone's
favorite movies is the jerk I know I've
seen it millions and millions of times
and that was one when Steve Martin was
his greatest and it would be so cool to
see if Steve Martin could go back into
that world and become that character
again because I think that's what he
needs in his career for all the people
that loved him in comedy and all his
films and I mean what can I say after I
thought of my answer I realized that
Harrison Ford has has done the movie
there was a seventh Star Wars movie that
showed what happened after Return of the
Jedi Harrison Ford was that guy got
killed by his son it all came to me
after I said it so even I'm gonna give
this point back
okay you know what I'm gonna call it
right here and give that point to read
ban Danielle - all right - - yes was up
a Pixar movie yes
dang it all right you know - too late
too late Jeremiah but uh your mind
trying to jump back Ben all right
question number three of the speedrun we
were locked up at 2:00 - gentlemen how
about it
Jumanji three entered production this
week what board game would inspire the
best movie Monopoly okay I will go with
Candyland I'm glad you didn't say Navin
R Johnson game yes it's a thing okay we
heard Monopoly first and Tony twenty
seconds again whatever you speak I think
it plays - today's a lot of today's
current issues you got your 1% hanging
over on the boardwalk all the way down
to the lowly people at Baltic and
Mediterranean Avenue this is a story
about a character that tries to make it
from being poor to being rich and has to
go through jail and so many different
problems while taking chances in getting
things from the Community Chest that
helped them and hurt
throughout their lives everyone likes
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
why not take it to the next level
Candyland will be a beautiful movie with
all the different sceneries and all the
different candy references who wants to
watch a movie about financial let's
let's it's got a Toys R Us and have a
good time with this game Tony
he said the S word ladies and gentlemen
and I still stand by it I just don't see
how Candyland is anything other than a
kids movie that would be made for kids
that weren't even around when Candyland
was a game Monopoly it's boring it's
long it's just about finance my mind
would be an amazing movie visually and
just be a lot of good good candy in
there all right Dan let's hear from you
I've Tony had the better pitch for me
I'm going with Tony
same here Tony good at this point it is
three two Tony going to question number
four it is game point for Tony by the
way with my mom in the house with a mom
you take this you win Tony Bryan you
need this to continue the game paramount
announced that Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles is getting a reboot who should
play shredder and the new Ninja Turtles
reboot ok I'm gonna go with Benicio del
Toro del Toro I'm gonna go with honey
booboo the kid yeah the kid from honey
booboo okay the kid from honey booboo
all right Tony 20 seconds begin whenever
you speak I've always looked at shredder
as a bit being very Darth Vader esque in
the way that I can see him speaking
through a voice changing type of mask
I think Benicio XY's and true acting
chops and everything that I've seen I
mean he knows how to use his
physicalities to his advantage and
shredder is one of the ultimate bad guys
of all time especially from someone in
my age group who Benicio has hit many
throughout with great work and I'd love
to see it it's a new you know with all
these reboots you have to do something
different to get attention and shredder
with a little kid voice would be
interesting and a lot of people would be
against it but I think once they get in
that movie theater and hear it there
could be I get it now I get it
I get it shredder is a little kid voice
[Laughter]
is unemployable at this point she
doesn't work anymore even on her former
hit reality show I don't I just don't
see how there's any way where they can
hire a little girl to play the role of a
grown man it's very easy using voice
changing technology that they have it
could be sent sounding really creepy I
think your choice you know he's who
cares about that guy I was really going
for Tony
I was really going for Tony on this one
but then you brought up the voice
changing technology and I'm still
completely going for this was actually
really hard first of all her name is
Alana I wish I didn't know that she is
on a TV show right now that's about her
mom so she is currently employed I know
way too much about honey boo boo um as
hilarious is the hints I have to go with
Tony you are today's movie fight
[Applause]
Congrats now you can think about your
fights your victory as you're cruising
in your Corvette yes and also think
about Brian flexing yeah
well played very funny Tony I want you
to go ahead and plug some stuff and tell
us where we can find you thank you so
much for having me I'm excited to
announce that kill Tony and the whole
crew is going to be at Montreal Just for
Laughs awesome and Toronto jfl 42 and
we're also doing our live podcast on the
road coming up in Detroit Lansing Grand
Rapids and Dallas Houston and Austin and
Fort Wayne Cleveland and perhaps
somewhere else
ya know Nashville thank you lots of
exciting stuff coming up awesome to hear
thank you so much for having me how much
fun I love ladies and I love fighting so
thank you but you hate Citizen Kane
that's right I should watch that tonight
hates it how well it's true yeah he
hates the idea it's the concept of
citizen yes Bryan thank you so much well
fought you took it to the speed round
and a lot of funny stuff in there as
well go ahead and well as you even
though it says red band on the screen
that's not my twitter name it's re DBA n
no D at the end okay off the last D for
savings yeah and you know and being do
it we've been doing kill Tony for a long
time but I've also been doing hundreds
and hundreds of different podcasts I
have a website death squad TV and now
you can find everything that I've ever
done all in video and audio awesome
Brian great having your brother Jeremiah
always funny
give us some plugs or just give us some
shout out some non sequiturs what do you
got
yeah funky on social media at Jeremiah
stand up I have a podcast that I do
called Jeremiah wonders and then
obviously we're on kill Tony together
and you know guys I fought today movie
fights with a broken arm so I did the
best that I can I got a hemorrhoid
everybody's playing hurt Dan Merle yes
what we're give us an update on you have
a big feud against the the folks behind
the gaudy movie gaudy movie twitter has
a feud with me how III have no beef with
them anymore
I mean I guess I do now but yeah don't
be nothing guys can you say that like in
like a Marlon Brando voice I got no beef
with Gotti
I have no disrespect forgot it yeah but
come on my house and disrespect me I
know they it's it's it's really not a
good movie and they want you to think
that it is but you know very funny and
compelling uh Twitter back and forth
check out dance Twitter like it I really
didn't like it
there's people some people like it sure
there's something like they like you
like Gotti that's great my problems with
the marketing is not with you go enjoy
your got a movie life's too short right
on Dan thank you for holding it down on
the facts
Daniel Radford checkout so I did some
punch up and some additional voices on a
max one podcast called bubble it is a
sci-fi narrative podcast
I think the a/v Club called it like
Portlandia meets Buffy meets something
meltdown oh but it's really funny and
y'all should go check it out and it's
got some actors who you will recognize
on there and then also just like me
continue to follow me on instagram
Danielle underscore Bradford and you
know you guys Courtney's aren't just for
Thursday's they're for every day of the
week you can continue to send me those
anytime you'd like excellent thank you
yeah and I second that my buddy Jordan
Morris is involved in that pod yes yeah
he is the writer of bubble is really
funny awesome thanks Danielle and I want
to thank you for watching movie fights
follow me on Twitter and Instagram oh
I'm really doing some stupid
nowadays on my Instagram stories to
check that out Hal Rudnick on both and
again thanks to all the kill Tony folks
and good luck Congrats on jfl and the
tour and congrats Tony for taking home
the victory we'll see you next time
movie fights my bike
you